it's a cold cold christmas in terms of
russia-nato relations as evidenced by
these russian troops undertaking firing
exercises near the border with ukraine
and of all the topics covered in
president putin's annual news conference
it was the questions about ukraine and
possible nato expansion which saw him
visibly bristling
we have made it explicitly clear that
further nato movement eastward is
unacceptable what is unclear about that
are we putting missiles next to the
united states borders no it is the
united states that has come to us with
their missiles they're already on our
doorstep
and in response to a question from a uk
news channel he highlighted the
historical context of the grievance
not one inch to the east is what we were
told in the 1990s and what happened we
were duped we were brazenly tricked
there were five waves of nato expansion
that's what we're talking about you have
to understand it's not us who are
threatening we didn't come to the
borders of the u.s or the uk you came to
us
ukraine gained its independence from the
soviet union in 1991 and although it's
cultivated close ties with europe some
parts remain deeply connected to russia
by history and language
in 2014 when euromaidan protests ousted
ukraine's pro-russian president russia
swiftly annexed the crimean peninsula
and supported pro-russian separatist
groups in the eastern region of donbass
but ukraine's express wish is membership
of nato and the european union an
ambition reiterated this week by
president zielinski
we want to unblock the donbass peace
process as soon as possible to return
crimea to gain membership of the
european union in upcoming years and to
get a very clear and very specific time
frame from nato and we want to get it in
2022.
the kremlin has tabled security
proposals which would effectively block
ukraine's nato ambitions russia has also
deployed tens of thousands of its troops
near to the ukrainian border
diplomats from the united states and
russia will meet to discuss the
proposals in january
nato is in an awkward position here an
attack against one nato member is
considered an attack against all so
while defending ukraine's right to
freely apply for nato membership the
alliance knows that granting membership
could bring nato troops face to face
with russian soldiers across a
battlefront
instead of these ukrainian soldiers
practicing with u.s supplied javelin
missiles it could be american troops
firing them for real
and russian soldiers firing back
paul brennan al jazeera